there's a new report about the
conditions in which migrant children are
being held and that report reveals that
in a converted Walmart where kids are
locked in a shelter with very little
outdoor time detained migrant kids are
being forced to recite the United States
Pledge of Allegiance one employee asked
why this is being done said that the
detained migrant children must respect
the Pledge of Allegiance
in order to respect the United States
the same Washington Post report exposes
that there are so many kids at some of
these centers that there are
prison-style head counts being done and
we actually got pictures of some of the
criminals being bused around very just
little kids I mean that this is it is
insane when you see little kids in
prison style buses which we are showing
our television audience right now
employees at the converted Walmart we're
also told to discourage the kids from
speaking their native language usually
Spanish although at some locations that
policy has reportedly been reversed the
absurdity of having to recite the pledge
which says in it with liberty and
justice for all
at a camp where children are being caged
I'd call it ironic but it's too soft a
word ironic would actually not do
justice to how crazy what's going on is
we don't want you in our country and we
don't even think you should necessarily
have constitutional rights but you'd
better pledge allegiance to our flag
anyway because otherwise I don't even
want to know what it is that would
happen to them I'm honestly at a loss
for words here there are so many irony
zits irony's built on top of iron yeah
it's an enigma wrapped in perversions of
justice is what I would call it and
while we're on the topic of the Pledge
of Allegiance we don't often talk about
the Pledge whenever we mention the
Pledge of Allegiance parents will email
me they'll say David I don't want my
kids saying the Pledge of Allegiance in
school but I don't want them to get into
trouble it's important to know that the
Supreme Court decided in 1943 students
cannot be required to recite the Pledge
of Allegiance
it follows from that that if you can't
be required to recite it you can't be
punished for not reciting it but the
problem is that lots of schools and
teachers don't know this
some of them might know but not care but
it is the law and unfortunately there is
a lot of stigma in schools in parts of
the country that still do the pledge for
not doing it and even the recitation of
the pledge is very cult-like I was lucky
enough to go to a school in a more
progressive place in in Western
Massachusetts where by the time I was in
middle school so roughly like 1996
the pledge was out but in a lot of parts
of the country this is still being done
and it really should end I think we
should get rid of it
at least you know when it comes to
singing in schools right because it is
cultish but also even if someone does
exercise the right not to say the Pledge
and they're not forced to do it by any
teacher or administrator it still
singles them out it's like stigmatizes
it a little bit people wonder why
they're not saying the Pledge like
everyone else yeah and so I get the
concern from parents even if they know
that the child can't be forced to say it
that the child can't strictly speaking
be punished for it you still are aware
of the fact that depending on which part
of the country your child goes to school
and there can be sort of implicit
consequences to it even if not formal to
wrap up the child internment angle of
the story I hope that history will judge
this phase and I hope it's just a phase
harshly in the future I don't know if
they will but I hope that when we look
back at this era it will be seen as a
black mark the black mark of this sort
of authoritarian Trump aside to the
right and I am NOT confident that that
will happen but I hope that it will send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show a day of not great news
today but we're here and we've got much
more coming up today's program is made
possible in part by fruit or which is a
social forecasting game for your phone
where players come together and compete
with each other to predict future events
you go on the app find a future event
you feel confident enough about to make
a prediction and make a bet on the
outcome that you think will happen using
the apps
in game fake currency if your prediction
is right you're rewarded with more
points you can compete with others who
are making their own prediction to see
who is the best forecaster there's no
real world money or cryptocurrency
involved the fun of futur is interacting
with others and showing the world your
skills at predicting the future will
Democrats take the White House house
this year will Trump run for re-election
will trump ever build the wall you can
go ahead and make your predictions show
off your forecasting skills and there
are also monthly competitions and prizes
for top forecasters and I'm on Foote or
you can wager on my predictions you can
also browse the politics category for
lots of interesting questions to go to
fruit or calm to sign up and make
forecast it's free it's on Android and
iOS as well as on web browsers and right
now on foote or you can win cash prizes
for correct predictions about the World
Cup check it out at fut you you are calm